hi everyone welcome to today's live
webinar rapid development and functional
analysis of mouse models using CRISPR
cast presented by dr. Jeremy Otto who is
a professor and associate director at
the NAB cardiovascular resource
Institute at the University of Rochester
on kevin holden of since ago and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
I begin I just want to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the flight
window to enlarge the window just click
the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation today please
click on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the lower
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to obtain your credits okay so
now I'd like to introduce our presenters
dr. Giuliano Giuliano received his PhD
in experimental pathology from the New
York Medical College the postdoctoral
training with Eric Olsen at MD Anderson
in Houston and where his first faculty
appointment with a Medical College of
Wisconsin where he worked mainly on the
role of retinoids as therapeutics for
vascular diseases
he was then recruited to University of
Rochester School of Medicine and
Dentistry where he is a full professor
and now the associate director of av
cardiovascular Research Institute dr.
Milot
as an editorial board member for several
journals and is an associate editor of
vascular pharmacology he has a past
associate editor of a TVB and consulting
editor for circulation of research in
addition he's also a fellow of the
American Heart Association and a member
of the Vascular cell and molecular
biology study section at NIH currently
Joe Aiello's research in his lab focuses
on deciphering how small snippets of
code in our genome can give cells
exquisite control over the level of gene
activity much like a thermostat
controlling the heat in your house he's
passionate about new technology the
deterrence research and it's lab was
among the first waves in 2013 to exploit
the revolutionary CRISPR Cassadine
genome engineering technology for
purposes of altering the mouse genome
within a year of his life's turning that
they generated the first CRISPR animal
model carrying subtle mutations in a
control element that turns on a gene
okay so also before we start I'd like to
give you a brief introduction on since
ago who is sponsoring this webinar today
since ago is a leading provider of
genome engineering solutions we are
headquartered in Silicon Valley and our
vision is to bring precision and
automation to genome engineering our
core competencies revolve around
engineering automation software
chemistry and synthetic biology and
we're going to what we've been able to
do with cyndago is actually generate a
new synthesis architecture that allows
us to generate a single guide single
guide RNAs chemically and we're going to
learn today a little bit about one of
the exciting applications of using
synthetic single guide RNA okay so I'd
like to hand it over to Satomi Ono for
their presentation and take it away Joe
thank you Kevin good morning everybody
or evening as the case may be
I'm going to be talking to you today
about CRISPR and this is the title and I
thought what I would do is begin with
the traditional method of modifying the
mouse genome and this turns out to be a
very labor-intensive series of steps
beginning with complex cloning of what's
called a targeting vector and that can
take anywhere from weeks to several
months and then the second hurdle to
overcome in this traditional mode of
modifying the mouse genome is to
introduce that targeting vector into
embryonic stem cells of the mouse that
is a very inefficient method typically
less than 1% of the cells will have
correct targeting and there's a
selection process and this can take
weeks to never and we've certainly
experienced than ever in the past so
moving along from that procedure we then
have to introduce these modified
embryonic stem cells into what's called
the blastocyst the mouse embryo to
create what's called a chimeric Mouse
and at this point the chimeric Mouse has
to be bred so that the modified es cell
is passed through the germline and
investigators can use the mice then for
experimentation and as you can see this
itself also takes from weeks to Never
so it's interesting to note is that this
traditional method of embryonic stem
cell targeting and homology
recombination won a Nobel Prize in 2007
only 10 years ago this procedure now has
been supplanted by CRISPR which is what
this webinar is all about and this is
just an introductory slide to remind me
to tell you that CRISPR is a natural
immune system in bacteria and at the end
of 2012 Jennifer Doudna and Emanuele
Charpentier showed that this system
could be repurposed for genome editing
so anything that has a genome can be
modified
what followed after that seminal paper
at the end of 2012 was literally an
avalanche of papers and books on crisper
and what this slide depicts is the fact
that crisper now supersedes its
predecessors talent and zinc finger
nucleases as the premier method for
modifying genomes so many of you are
across the globe and this reminds me to
tell you that we really have now what I
call global crisper ization
crisper is reached into agriculture and
so now we have modified agriculture the
way of tomatoes that will not rot and
wheat that will not mold so we can feed
the world it's it has ramifications for
controlling insects such as the mosquito
that carries malaria more closer to us
there's now more than 20 somatic genome
editing trials using CRISPR here in the
United States and then there's the ever
controversial germline genome editing in
humans and this has garnered a lot of
attention in recent years and it's just
a sampling of some of the books that
have been published some of you may have
recalled the movie Gattaca which was way
ahead of its time that movie came out 20
years ago and really what we're entering
now as a species humanity is some really
unchartered territory and among the many
questions we'll be having and our kids
will be having will be the one depicted
in the lower right there as we court we
will be asking one another such things
as how is your genome and how do we deal
with any mutations that either of us
might carry how do we safeguard our
children in the next generation and
CRISPR will have a heavy hand in
answering those questions so as I said
this is a global CRISPR ization but
today what I want to talk about is
germline and genome editing
in the mouse and that will be the
subject of this talk so that is the
mouse is a very important laboratory
animal why do we use the mouse it's
cheap has a very short generation time
and we have a lot of genetics that we
know about the mouse we can Fino copy or
model if you will human diseases in the
mouse and that allows us the opportunity
to develop novel therapeutic modalities
to treat human disease I thought it
would be instructive to let you know
what the focus of my lab is and so what
we're interested in Kevin touched upon
this and his introductory comments so
we're interested in elucidating the
function of non-coding sequences those
includes long non-coding RNAs which
there are hundred thousand or more
enhancers regulatory elements we're
interested in modeling human coding and
non-coding snips again towards the
development of potential therapies for
human consumption we're also interested
in tagging endogenous jeans with epitope
tags like flag for example and I'll be
touching upon each of these in the next
several slides so that's the preamble of
my presentation and now I want to get
into the actual webinar if you will I've
divided this webinar into two parts part
one will be some CRISPR basics and then
part two will be some CRISPR examples
so crisper and it's simplest form can be
thought of as a two-component system
made up of an endonuclease and a
synthetic guide RNA both of which can be
purchased from cent ago at the following
web site the endonuclease that is the
most popular one is from this bacteria
shown in red here strep pyogenes or SP
cast 9 now this endonuclease by itself
has very little if any enzymatic
activity
it requires interactions with the single
guide RNA for its activity and what
happens when this ribonucleoprotein or
RMP complex forms is it rapidly diffuses
across the genome and surveil looking
for two things one is the complimentary
sequence that the user defines that's in
red the red stippled sequence there
within this RMP and then the second
thing is what's called a pam sequence or
proto spacer adjacent motif so
encountering when encountering this
combination of the complimentary
sequence and the pam sequence the RMP
undergoes structural changes that now
allows it to do its job of cutting DNA I
should mention that in the design tools
such as the one at synth ago the pam
sequence is not included in in the
design of the single guide RNA and this
was a frequent error in the early days
when people were first using this
technology so upon the enzymatic
activity and what's called the double
strand break which is very difficult to
see but I hope you can appreciate it
that little break in the double helix
inside the yellow cast 9 these breaks
are incompatible with the life of the
cell the cell has natural repair
mechanisms to
such double-strand breaks and one is
called an hej for non-homologous end
joining and this is an error-prone
repair system and because it's
error-prone random insertions deletions
or substitutions occur and the
consequence of that is a frameshift and
if it's a reading frame of a protein a
premature stop a disruption in a splice
site or even the removal of critical
regulatory elements of its near the
promoter region now this two component
CRISPR system the simplest form of
CRISPR is very efficient upwards of
seventy or eighty percent efficient but
it's inaccurate as I indicated but
thankfully there's a third component
what we call three component CRISPR and
now this third component is a donor DNA
and this donor DNA typically is a single
strand oligonucleotide that again like
the single guide RNA can be user-defined
and if you look carefully in that edited
DNA you'll see a little red stipple and
that is an engineered if you will base
so the user can can modify the
oligonucleotide to his or her liking to
create very subtle substitutions the
consequence of that is highly precise
genome editing for correcting mutation
for modeling snips for making condition
alleles putting in epitope tags fine
mapping elements and so forth now in
contrast to the two component system
three component CRISPR is not as
efficient typically in the order of 10%
or so but it is very very accurate and
this is the system that's going to be
exploited clinically to treat human
disease so now I thought I would do with
that little background it's just take
you through a series of steps so how
exactly one goes about making a CRISPR
Mouse so the first step is a very
important step and that's the strategy
and typically I take about three to four
hours of carefully going through and
defining exactly how to design the
single guide RNA and it's necessary the
single strand Allah go if it's three
component CRISPR now as you can see
there's two very important
considerations one is to know your gene
locus and what you see here is a
screenshot from the UCSC genome browser
and you can see the URL there and I
would urge you to visit that browser and
look up your favorite team because you
need to know things like for example in
this case where you see the red circle
if you're targeting Hawks a11 then you
may have a problem because you can see
that right below it is a long non-coding
coding RNA called Hawks a 11 OS for
opposite strands so you can imagine that
if you were targeting in this case Hawks
a 11 you would also be targeting that
long non-coding RNA which would
introduce a confounding variable in your
experimental results so pay particular
attention to this very very key step of
strategizing so once you've got the
strategy you'd need to then order the
single guide RNA and we in the Mian o
lab or all of our guide RNA some simple
very high quality synthetic guide RNAs
they are high-scoring meaning that they
are very specific with low numbers of
predicted off targets and will be talked
about off targeting later on very
importantly if doing precision guided
editing and modeling a snip or
correcting a mutation it's important to
recognize that where the double strand
break occurs in relation to that point
mutant is very very important it should
be within 10 base pairs if it's much
further away the efficiency of
incorporating that mutation Falls
dramatically finally another very
important consideration is designing a
an optimized and robust genotyping
protocol and I'll talk a little bit
about that in a moment
the next step once and it takes about a
week to get the reagents from cyntha go
but upon receiving the reagents one
should test the single guide RNA for
activity in combination with the caste 9
protein now this can be done in cells by
trans sections some people even do it
directly into mouse embryos but we do a
very simple tube assay which since ago
provides instructions too and this is
very reminiscent to doing a restriction
digest in a tube and so by combining the
caste 9 protein with your synthetic
guide RNA and a PCR product containing
the target site and incubating for an
hour or less at 37 degrees you can run
out it on a gel and see in this case the
cut work now why is it much darker than
the uncut well that's the the single
guide RNA which is also picked up by the
cyber green staining now I can tell you
we've been using products from synth ago
for the last year and we haven't had any
trouble whatsoever and we've done over a
dozen Mouse projects with the reagents
so they're very robust and they always
work knock on wood
having tested the core reagents the
guide RNA in cast nine one should really
test PCR primers around the genomic
region it's going to be edited and also
the genotyping what I call duplex PCR
assay for detecting even single nucleus
nucleotide changes one may also want to
test for potential off target sites this
can be done either in a biased fashion
or unbiased fashion the bias fashion
would be using a program such as one
from crisp or or synth ago and I'll show
this a little later
and then there's some complicated
unbiased assays called circles seek and
site seek and guide seek and these are
reviewed you'll see at the bottom in
this paper in a TVB from 2016 and that
would you to look at this paper as it
has a lot of details
a lot of references moving right along
now to generating the mouse this takes
the longest time but the good news is is
that you really won't have to do much
except to hand off to your
microinjection Asur electroporator the
single guy at iron a cast 9 and i'll go
nucleotide if necessary they will do the
rest then about three weeks later or
four weeks one week after the pups are
born you'll get toe clips that you can
then use your optimized PCR assay to
detect your edits and then you can start
breeding the mice to pass the Edit
through the germline and I should point
out that germline transmission is very
very efficient 90% or more not true with
the conventional ESL approach that I
talked about at the very beginning I'll
just remind you to just pay close
attention to the strain of mouse that
you're using typically c57 black 6 mics
are used because they have a rich
history as far as genetic modifications
go the final step which is perhaps the
step that everybody really looks forward
to is phenotyping the genetically
modified mice
so one should definitely pay attention
to Mendelian ratios expression analysis
of the edited gene to ensure it's
knocked out histological analyses and
oftentimes quote unquote knockouts may
not show any obvious phenotype unless
they're stressed in some manner whether
it be through some experimental disease
model or crossing the crisperize Mouse
into another genetic background
so to summarize these basics I just want
to point out that this is very very
simple the hardest part would be the
front
strategizing and making sure that you're
targeting something that's targetable
and will reveal an important phenotype
testing the reagents and then the core
will do the rest
and so literally within five to six
weeks from conception to genotyping one
can have a mouse and this should be
compared and contrasted with the
traditional method which six months is
the best is the fastest I've ever heard
anybody making a mouse with the
traditional method of ESL typically it
takes a year or more and as I said at
the beginning sometimes it never happens
at all but with CRISPR incredibly
efficient okay so that's the first part
of this webinar now I want to move in to
some examples some anecdotes if you will
of how we in my lab have used CRISPR to
modify the mouse to reveal some really
important information that otherwise
would be difficult to get even with the
traditional method of making knockout
mice so I want to start out with our
favorite subject which is non-coding DNA
and this slide here just shows the
non-coding sequence in white and then an
exon in orange we in my lab are very
very interested in the 98% of the genome
that doesn't encode for protein there's
a lot of functional information in there
the notion that our genome is largely
junk DNA has been debunked we now know
largely from encode that most of our
genome is functional so as I said
earlier there's perhaps we'll more than
100,000 non-coding genes there are
literally millions of these little
snippets that Kevin mentioned at the
beginning that we call transcription
factor binding sites that control gene
expression but perhaps the most relevant
reason for studying the non-coding
portions of genome is that most disease
variants fall in this sequence space and
we know very very little about how these
variants contribute to disease
so in the first example and this turns
out to be the very first project we ever
did and we started this in 2013 and it
was published at the end of 2014 this is
a three component so three CS three
component CRISPR the three components
being an HDR single strand algo HDR
incidentally is an acronym for homology
directed repair a cast nine mRNA and a
single guide RNA so these were early
days precent ago so this was an all RNA
approach what you see here is the top is
a locus of a gene called Cal ponen CNN
one you see the two exons in blue and
then in that first intron are four lines
one of which is green and the green one
is expanded below and in green and that
sequence is one of these little snippets
of DNA and we call this particular
binding site a card box and so we had
reason to believe that by mutating very
in a very subtle way this card box we
might have a phenotype and so below that
sequence you see there's an orange line
and that just schema ties as the single
guide on RNA and then the pam sequence
very importantly and you'll notice it's
not part of the single guide RNA design
is boxed and one thing I should point
out is that these card boxes end in the
Pam and gg making them very suitable
substrates for precision editing so
you'll notice below that sequence
another sequence in red and those are
the faces that were substituted for the
corresponding bases apology and so you
can see that this is a five base pair
substitution three of which include the
CCT of the card box this is a very very
subtle substitution so what happens well
before we find out what happens we need
to genotype these mice so how do you
genotype a mouse that has only five
bases that have been substituted so we
came up with this assay years ago we
call it a duplex PCR assay
which we use a common reverse primer and
then two forward primers the forward
wild-type primer has an extended
sequence of between 35 and 40
nucleotides and then the forward mutant
primer does not have that extended
sequence but n in red with the mutations
that have been introduced and so by
using these three primers together in
one PCR tube one can very easily and
robustly genotype the mice and so here
you see the result of that particular
duplex PCR you can see the wild-type is
a large band of the heterozygous has
both bands and then the mutant has a
lower band because the four mutant
primer is short so we've used this a
particular PC our approach in multiple
projects now with very high degree
success so what happens to these mice
well this was an astonishing result by
making these subtle substitutions in one
single transcription factor binding site
we've virtually abolished the binding of
the transcription factor to that card
box called SR F so this is a chip assay
and you see very very little if any
binding of srf to there card box and
then this was the Shocker very little in
the way of expression of the target gene
kalpona either at the mRNA level or at
the right protein level in a Western
blot this is amazing so so a single
element mutated abolish it's virtually
the expression of this particular target
gene here's some immuno has to chemistry
to further the point you see on the top
the wild-type condition and in red or
off red depending on your screen you see
from left to right in the uterus and
then in blood vessels of the kidney and
heart the mammary gland those are my
orbital cells in red the aorta and then
this the smooth muscle in the small
intestine the corresponding mutants have
very little in the way of expression of
kalpona
consistent with the mRNA data
one of the things we like to do when we
do these kinds of edits of transcription
factor binding sites is to ensure we've
not knocked out other genes so here's an
irony seek that shows that in fact
kalpona is massively down regulated in
the mutants but then there's very little
in the way of change elsewhere so we're
confident that the mutations that we
introduced only affected Cal ponen
directly and not other genes that
potentially you might share that on it
now the second example I want to give
you is an extension of the first one so
now here it's exactly the same design
exactly the same locus an element only
now you'll see we're introducing a
single base edit and this was really to
provide proof of principle data to
support an endeavor to look at real
snips in the human genome
modeling them in the mouse to find out
what the consequences are so we've made
a single base change the C to gene
mutation and notice again the design so
we were very careful in in our choosing
that particular base because what we
were able to do was to introduce a sec
to restriction site and we used that in
a slightly different PCR assay what we
call a restriction fragment length
polymorphism assay in which we PCR
around the mutation and digest that PCR
product was act 2 to reveal the genotype
and again now you can see very
unambiguously define each of the
genotypes in these mice which is a very
important consideration in your design
very similar to the preceding model
where we had five substitutions a single
base change is enough to virtually
abolish expression of this kalpona gene
in the aorta interestingly the bladder
less so and we don't understand the
reason for that and just here's some
more supportive data again like before
showing that
protein level very little if any kalpona
and protein in vessels of the heart and
in the aorta but some in the bladder
still and i should point out that this
project was using our MPs from synthe
ago so the Cassadine protein and the
single guide RNA now there are many
other examples my lab primarily focuses
on non-coding sequences so we do things
like delete and enhancers or putative
enhancers by tens of KB in some cases
but in the interest of time I want to
move along to the second vignette if you
will and that involves disrupting coding
genes or protein coding genes so now
we're going to talk about to see or to
component CRISPR targeting exon one of a
gene called liya mode in one and when I
was a postdoc in Eric Olsen's lab when
we cloned a new gene we didn't know what
it did we knocked it out now today
that's very easy to do and I'm going to
show you how easy it is we generated
this and I should point out that this
Mouse originally we tried to make this
mouse the conventional way and we never
got it so this was one of the failed
projects using the ESL approach of
yesteryear we got this particular Mouse
in about two months now what you'll see
here in exon one at the top are three
upside-down triangles those signify
single guide RNAs this was an all RNA
approach this was our second project so
we use cast nine mRNA and the
consequence of that was we created a
deletion in the first exon that caused
the frame shift so from at the junction
from the black sequence to the red
sequence that's the frame shift and that
resulted in a premature stop codon so
this was a very severe mutation this
protein as you can see is normally 595
amino acids but we only had eight amino
acids at the n-terminus and then it was
a nonsense mutation at the end
now this was clearly a knockout as shown
on the bottom-left in a Western blot you
see no detectable lie mode in one and
then below that is some
immunofluorescence microscopy of the
aorta showing no detectable lam mode one
by a middle fluorescence microscopy now
the phenotype of this mouse was very
interesting I'm in a cardiovascular
research group when we saw this result
we scratched our head and wondered what
happened to the gut so you can see in
the knockout the animal has an enlarged
gut a large stomach that's milk in the
stomach these animals did not survive
much more than a week after being born
and they had a very very severe
phenotype it turns out that this is a
phenotype that occurs in a very small
segment of the human population and in
fact in this particular case the probe
and young girl died of very rare
disorder and this was due to the fact
that she had a mutation much like the
one in the mouse that caused loss of lie
more than one now here's an example of
where we've modelled a human disease in
the mouse and so now we can use this
mouse model to gain insights into
potential therapeutic modalities to
treat this devastating disease so it
turns out that there are many many many
papers published already using CRISPR
exactly along the lines I just shared
with you with respect to disrupting
protein encoding genes but I want to
move along now to one of my more
favorite applications and that is
epitope tagging in the mouse genes whose
protein products are otherwise very
difficult to detect and I'm sure some of
you can relate to this how many times
have you bought an antibody only to find
out that it didn't work it's very
frustrating so what
the transcription factors we study in
the lab is a cofactor called Milo Carden
and Milo Carden works with this s RF
transcription factor I mentioned earlier
over these card boxes to drive
expression uniquely in smooth muscle
cells shown as a transmission electron
micrograph on the right now for many
many years we in a host of other labs
thought we were detecting mild Cardon
which has a predictive molecular weight
of about 100 kilotons and what you see
below is a Western blot showing a band
that seemingly smile carton but when we
do a robust authentication experiment
using SI RNA 2-mile carton we can see
while we definitely get a reduction in
the mRNA level of mild carton there's no
reduction in the corresponding protein
raising suspicion as to whether that
truly is milo carton and so we use three
component CRISPR to tag the c-terminus
and there's some considerations when
doing this one of which is whether it's
an or C terminus so we did a series of
experiments and determined that the C
terminus was the way to go
there you see the 3 X flag this was an
RMP experiment we chose flag for reasons
I don't have time to go into but one
thing I will point out is that there are
many tags to use I've only shown three
here and one of the things that's cool
about CRISPR is it can be multiplexed
and so it's conceivable that one can use
multiple eligos containing different
epitope
tags in one injection and then sort out
the pups that will have each reporter or
epitope and there are a number of labs
that do this
it saves an amazing amount of time so
one of the first things we learned was
that the molecular weight of mild card
is not a hundred kilohms it's like more
like 150 kiloton as shown in this
western blot on the left and then we did
this authentication experiment in Mouse
a or tech smooth muscle cells and you'll
notice the wild-type smooth muscle cells
in a dish show no detectable
but then when we did the si RNA
knockdown in contrast to the earlier
experiment we do indeed see a loss in
this 150 kiloton band similarly in an
immuno fluorescence microscopy
experiment in cultured smooth muscle
cells we see my au carton on the top but
when we knock it down in the bottom we
see it gone and so this just reminds me
to tell everybody that when doing your
experiments to be transparent and to be
rigorous finally since this is a
transcription factor we can use the
antibody to flag in what's called a chip
seek and these are experiments that are
underway right now so the last model
organism or I should say application of
CRISPR in the mouse is one that is a
favorite of many which is to use CRISPR
to make a conditional allele in the
mouse so in the original method from UD
Rudy anisha's lab published in cell this
was a three-component CRISPR that used
to guide RNAs to oligos and a caste 9
mRNA now it turns out that this is a
very inefficient method and it's fraught
with mutations and we did try it this
was probably our third or fourth
experiment back in the day and we
targeted the a cap 12 locus but as you
see we only had one pop out of 41 that
was positive and I should point out that
that one pup had mutations in the loxp
site so this clearly was not for us
something worth pursuing
since then we've turned to what's called
sequential injections where we do one
injection at a time and this works very
well with no mutations the problem is is
it takes as long as it would take using
an ESL approach there are other methods
that are faster that I don't have time
to go into but perhaps maybe raised
during the Q&A and this just shows using
a PCR that we had three mice that had
correct excision of this component to
gene so some final thoughts about CRISPR
in the mouse
so one is the RNP approach so using cast
9 protein with a synthetic guide RNA
while it results in a lower number of
life-form pops as shown on the left in
this box whisker plot has a phenomenally
better HDR efficiency that is to say we
get more pops that have the correct
mutation using this RNP approach and
that probably relates to the fact that
when we inject the RMP into the zygote
we're getting very very rapid editing
and very accurate editing there's no
escaping mosaicism and mosaicism is this
phenomenon that is rampant in CRISPR and
it's a particular problem with human
germline genome editing but in the mouse
it's less of a problem as you'll see in
a moment but basically what it reflects
is the fact that cast 9 isn't always
perfect it may not work until the second
cell division or it may work for a
prolonged period of time and the result
is a mouse or a series of mice with
different flavors if you will of
mutations or edits now we can sort
through that and here is an example this
was from our model carton 3x flag mouse
where we used primers flanking the 3x
flag and what you see below our real
data from independent mice this is tail
snips and you'll appreciate the fact
that there's a whole series of different
alleles and it looks kind of confusing
and we want to make sure that we get
what we're striving for and so by simply
modifying the forward primer such that
it's a hybrid between Maya carton and
flag we can see in the bottom that this
mess up above can be sorted out very
very conveniently and so this is how we
screen against mosaicism and get the
desired allele finally
the business of off targeting now this
is a huge issue in cells in a dish as
well as in human embryos but in the
mouse it turns out it may not be as big
an issue because of Mendel's law of
independent assortment so if there's an
off target site that's more than 2
million base pairs from your on target
site circled in red then because of
Mendel's laws those edits will go away
after one or two generations however if
the edit off target edit occurs in
linkage disequilibrium or lb then it
could be an issue and needs to be
addressed how do we address it well
there are programs thankfully and here's
one from again synth ago who's
sponsoring this webinar you see on the
top the synthetic guide RNA and then
below our oft arc predicted off target
sites now in this case Miele carton
lives in chromosome 11 and if you just
scan down this short list you don't see
any off targets on chromosome 11 so I
personally would not worry about any of
those off target edits because they
would probably vanish in the first
generation or two so I want to just
close by saying that CRISPR editing in
the mouse is incredibly fast and
cost-effective the record time we've
made a mouse with this CRISPR technology
is five weeks from design to genotyping
so you can't go any faster than that at
least in the mouse phenomenally great
HDR efficiency upwards of 40% now in
some dozen or so projects since we've
switched over to synth agos synthetic
guide RNA and cast iron protein is the
first a'tall system I shared with you
some genotyping protocols that are very
robust and then the issues of mosaicism
and not targeting are issues but not so
much so in the mouse and so finally I
just want to thank my colleagues and
these are the true pioneers of the field
some of whom are going to win a Nobel
Prize and with that I will turn it back
over to Kevin for the Q&A
all right thank you Joe very much for
that very informative presentation
all right so we'll now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question that you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for and if we're not able to get to
your questions today then they will be
answered via email following the
presentation all right so let's get
started okay let's take a look here our
first question here
Joe is do I need to test sgrna s for
activity before injecting so the
question the answer is yes what as I
indicated earlier there are a number of
ways to test synthetic guide RNAs the
most labor intensive and expensive would
be to inject it into a mouse as I go let
the zygote develop to the blastocyst
stage and then take the cells from the
blastocyst and do PCR and other believe
it or not their lab to do that frankly I
think it's a colossal waste of time and
what we do is a very simple tube assay
and I can tell you thus far every single
tube a say that's revealed the single
guide RNAs activity is being active and
they always are worked in the mouse now
I have a colleague at Michigan who's
done a lot more projects than me and he
tells me on a very very rare day there
isn't a one-to-one correspondence but
the answer is absolutely should test
this the single guide RNA at least in a
tube assay
okay great thanks for that and actually
you know just before we go on and on to
any further questions hopefully you're
all on the last slide and we just want
to remind you we just you know say thank
you but we also want to remind you that
you can actually try the guide RNA it's
a single guide RNAs from cyndago for
free if you just follow the web address
on the bottom of the flight sim to go
comm slash lab words okay so also the
next question Joe here we've got one and
the question here says how fast can i
generate a Kris Bryant Mouse from
conceiving a plan to getting correctly
genotype pups yeah this is fantastic so
the old way as I mentioned earlier could
be it's typically in the order of a year
to get a mouse the old way with ESL
technology with with CRISPR and the
synthetic guide RNA and cast iron
protein we've done it in five weeks from
conception of the idea so as soon and
believe me it the sky's the limit with
this technology since one can generate
mice so quickly as soon as we have an
idea of doing something whether it's a
point mutation or deletion or knocking
in an epitope tag I'm on the computer
immediately and as I indicated earlier
it takes me a couple hours to sort of
design it all then we order it if I
start in the morning we order at that
same day of course we have you guys have
to synthesize it it takes a little while
to do then you have great quality
control so we want good product so we
were very patient when we wait during
that week and as soon as it comes in we
put it into the core and it gets
injected and then four weeks later we
get toe clips to genotype so literally
you can't do it faster than five weeks
depending on the core if you have to
wait a while it could be longer of
course but I would say anywhere from
five weeks to it shouldn't be more than
a couple two month to three months at
the most but but bear in mind very very
little hands on very very little just
the front end testing of the guide RNA
for activity a little bit of PCR making
sure your genotyping primers work and so
on but then after that you're just
waiting for the toe clips to
why your your optimized genotyping
protocol and you're off to the races
alright great thanks for that Joe
question we got here is how can we
increase efficiency of the three
component system sure so one way would
be to get away from an RNA approach and
go to the InP approach as I mentioned so
rather than use believe it or not
there's some labs I know that will do
the cast nine in vitro transcription in
their lab do the purification I mean
this is just a waste of time precious
time so I urge the listeners to to by
synthetic guide RNAs and and use them in
the experimentation there are a whole
host of ways to increase efficiencies
from using inhibitors of the
non-homologous end joining repair system
to using shorter synthetic guide RNAs
ki-jung I know I've done that but I have
to be a we haven't changed anything in
the two years or so since we've really
hit our stride we've made over thirty
strains of mice in that timer interval
which is ten times the number we made
previously with the Esso we really
haven't had any trouble using the
standard cast nine with with a synthetic
guide RNA of 20 nucleotides and an ala
gonna CLIA tied with a with a point
mutation or the insert placed at the
middle of that algo nucleotide alright
let's go we got have another question
here and you want to know Kris for
editing be used with all almost human
cancers so I'm not a physician but one
of the trials actually there's probably
several trials now is to use CRISPR for
purposes of treating cancer and one of
the the highest profile ones would be
the car t-cell so that there's now been
clearance to use these modified t
lymphocytes and they've been crisp
Erised so these are patients t-cells are
taken out of the body and they're
modified so that they the t-cells can
attack just the tumor and not healthy
cells and kill the tumor so I think it
would be an overstatement to say say
that we we've cured cancer but I do
believe in our lifetime certainly my
lifetime and certainly in the youngsters
lifetime out there a lot of the cancers
are going to be amenable to treatment
using CRISPR genome editing alright
thanks for those insights Joe we've got
another question here it's a good one
compared to non CRISPR methods could
lower the lower number of puffs you see
possibly be due to higher frequency of
off-target effects with CRISPR I would I
would say no to that we frankly don't
even test for off targeting anymore
unless it's very close to the on target
at it most in most cases the off
targeting occurs distal to the on target
site so we ignore it
I think what's contributing to the lower
number of live born pups since we've
switched over to the RMP has a lot to do
with the c57 black strain of mouse
because when we injected fvb strain for
example which was a very popular still
is very popular strain of mouse for
making transgenics
they tolerate pro-nuclear injection very
well but the black six strain doesn't
tolerate it so well and nobody knows
why whether it has to do with the
nuclear envelope or the architecture of
the genome but it's not just us that
have seen this drop in the number of
life-form pops it's others now I should
say and I failed to mention this during
the talk that we were up until recently
doing nuclear injections even with the
RMP we've since now switched to
cytoplasmic injections and when one does
a cytoplasmic injection the cast nine
protein has a nuclear localization
signal in it actually I think the ones
you guys make have too and so even
though it's injected in the cytoplasm it
will ferry into the nucleus and find its
target and perform the edit we've done
one project in that manner cytoplasmic
injection and we saw a pretty good bump
up in the number of live born pups and
so it's early days but we've switched
over now to cytoplasmic injections and
we're hopeful that we'll get more pups
but frankly we haven't needed more pups
as I also pointed out even though the
pup yield is low since the HDR
efficiency is much higher I mean for
example we had a project just recently
the last week we have one live born pop
that one live worm pop was positive so
that was incredible so I think that
it'll be fine doing cytoplasmic
injections and there'll be just much
that many more positives to sort of sort
through or to have if one wants to
really test every single positive pup
for the phenotyping speaking of speaking
of brief breeding puffs Joe we have
another question here it says when
breeding minds how do you ensure by
allelic editing do you crossbreed
heterozygous mice
so our genotyping is very robust so most
of our of our three component CRISPR
projects our point mutations or multiple
base substitutions and so when we do
this type of genotyping we sometimes not
always we sometimes do see by allelic
targeting but I want to caution the
questioner and letting them know that
when we're genotyping these pups these
are founder animals they're mosaics so
even though they're by allelic not every
single cell in the body of that founder
Mouse has both of those targeted it's
just from the tissue we took from which
is a toe clip so if one takes the liver
or the heart or the spleen or a tail
snip that by allylic targeting may not
hold up but by allelic targeting does
occur in our hands it's not so frequent
but we do see it and sometimes we can
phenotype from it but it whether they're
by allelic or heterozygous is really
immaterial because at the end of the day
that Mouse has to be bred back to the
parent strain the black stick strain in
this case for germline transmission so
that every cell has that edit so one can
do some phenotyping on the founders but
I wouldn't publish a paper based on
founder phenotyping for sure
all right Jenna thanks for that we have
a couple of technical questions actually
now maybe you can answer about CRISPR
the first one is actually a two-part
question purity for that it's in general
how much of the guide RNA which be
injecting is in and what they also would
like to know is is there a correlation
between the amount of guide rnas and the
number of live embryos that you get and
the second part of that question if you
will is have you compared
double-stranded DNA single-stranded DNA
for uses as donor DNA okay so take the
second one first yes we did one project
in the early days with double strand DNA
it did not work and since then we have
not double strand DNA is a little more
complicated since it's double stranded
the the repair the integration of the
substitution or deletion or insertion
whatever the case may be
is a very complicated one and we still
don't understand it all but it's not
homologous recombination a lot of people
think that it's even though we talk
about the HDR template on what homology
directed repair a template and one
thinks of homologous recombination but
it really truly isn't it's it's single
strand annealing to the template that's
been chewed back or respected if you
will so single strand annealing of the
single strand a logo and in the case of
the double strand DNA that becomes very
inefficient right cause it's double
strand DNA and at 37 degrees how do how
do you get that melting if you will for
single strand annealing to the respected
template so so the the simple answer is
is that we do not in my lab do double
strand DNA integration now I know other
labs do but we just because of the
nature of our work we have no need for
it frankly and now with easy CRISPR for
making conditional eels which is easy
CRISPR involves the synthesis of single
strand olive those that can be up to
three thousand nucleotides in length so
conditional alleles now can be made very
easily with a
with a very long single channel ago so
we have no need for double strand DNA
and we certainly haven't done any
one-to-one comparison in a serious way
now the first question which is a very
deep question about the concentration of
single guys RNA we actually use the same
concentration that Rudy anus used in his
cell paper we have not changed from that
really at all we haven't done any
experimentation with respect to the
concentration of the single guide RNA
and live born pops frankly because we
haven't needed to and we have so many
projects we want to do we don't have
time to do these these experiments that
frankly for me aren't going to really be
helpful because we're already we already
have it wired well with the conditions
we have now alright Joe thanks for that
looks like there's time for just a
couple more questions so one of them is
how did how do you decide whether to tag
the end or c-terminus in your epitope
tagging project that's a good question
so or the middle for that matter so some
people will tag the middle of a protein
with with a with an epitope tag so for
us it all has to do with splicing so
Maya Carden which is the only
transcription factor we've tagged to
date has four splice variants and those
splicing events as is most the case
occur at the end terminus so we wanted
to capture all the splice variants and
that's one of the reasons why we put it
at the c-terminus so that way we get all
four splice isoforms of my car that
wouldn't be the case if we went to the n
terminus but there's another reason the
N terminus has a very important
functional domain and we were worried
about disrupting that and so we did some
preliminary experiments in vitro where
we made an n-terminal versus a c
terminal flag tag or Mik tag mile Cardon
and then we just looked at its ability
to transactive eight reporters and what
we found was the c terminus was the best
place so for two reasons for splicing
and for for activity we put it at the c
terminus
very very important question and I think
before one dies in and just willy-nilly
celexa and versus see by a coin toss
there should be some due diligent
homework before making that important
decision all right so it looks like we
have time for just one more question
here and it's another kind of technical
design question and it's does the
location of the pants sequence matter it
sounds like the person asking this
question has found there are several
pants sequences in the region where
they're trying to edit one it's upstream
of the proto spacer the other is
downstream in general you do Jemmy
recommendations for how far away from
the Pam sequence you should do the edits
and if there's any directionality that
you see it's a really good question so
the person asking that question is well
aware of these design tools that will
show Pam sequences on the plus and minus
strand the key the the most important
thing is to get that Pam sequence as
close to for example the base that you
wish to edit as possible so we typically
we've been very fortunate
particularly with card boxes as I
pointed out they end and begin on the
opposite strand with Pam sequences so
they really make for nice substrates for
crisper editing but you want it to be as
close as possible now what if it isn't
so there there certainly will be
instances where there may be a Pam maybe
if it's an 18 rich region for example
and there may not be a Pam for like a 20
30 40 50 nucleotides what do you do then
well it turns out that there are a whole
series of crisper nucleases now
available to the to the molecular
biologists and and and the toolkit has
is expanding it seems every other month
with a new cast 9 nucleus so there's CPF
one which recognizes an 18 rich Pam
sequence and so it we're at the point
now and I talked to a number of pioneers
about this literally any nucleotide in
the genome can be edited with given the
toolkit that we
have in the present day now of course
there's chromatin accessibility and so
forth but in theory any nucleotide in
this six billion three billion or so
nucleotides in our genome can be edited
so one just needs to be aware of the
different nucleases available in
instances when the ngg pam for strep
pyogenes cast nine may not be close
enough all right so well that's the end
of our Q&A session thanks very much for
taking part of that and for all your
insights those are fantastic really
appreciate hearing your experience doing
CRISPR in the mouse and also a really
deep understanding of Mouse biology
which i think is essential for people
doing this kind of work just before we
wrap up Joe I want to ask a real quick
if you have any final comments for the
audience I would just say typically I've
been talking about CRISPR now around the
world really for the last four years or
so and I always pull the audience it's
small or large my first question always
is who's using CRISPR and it amazes me
that it's far less than 50% so a lot of
people are not using and I'm I'm worried
that maybe they're a bit intimidated by
it because they're probably getting
spammed with all kinds of promises about
making a CRISPR mouse or making a CRISPR
cell line from all these companies and
what I always tell them I said look this
is what works for us and if you follow
what I've been telling you what I told
you today you will have success I
guarantee you will have success so I
think the my final comment is if you've
been thinking about it stop thinking
about it and start doing it because as
soon as you start seeing how amazing it
is how efficient it is and what you can
do with it
then the only limitation is your
imagination and you'll be doing CRISPR
your entire scientific career so I guess
I'll just leave it at that well put Joe
definitely well put okay so just to kind
of wrap up will
make sure that we get to any unethical
questions will reach out to the people
and ask the questions directly Joe dr.
me oh no dr. Joe me oh no I'd like to
thank you again for hosting this webinar
with since ago I think it was really
informative and fantastic and you know
just before we go I would like to let
everybody know once again if you go to
the web link
since ago calm slash lab routes you're
welcome to try the synthetic SD RNAs for
free for your for your first CRISPR
experiment and also like to let you know
that this webinar will be available for
on-demand viewing on our website shortly
so I'd like to thank you all for your
time wherever you are logging into from
all over the world and again what's
Thank You Joanna
appreciate it all right goodbye
everybody thank you